grand perdant à la présidentielle le
voilà de retour
benoît hamon a lancé son mouvement
génération pour conquérir un nouvel
électorat de gauche c'est à dijon à
l'hôpital de la chartreuse en grève
depuis 35 jours que son discours sur le
service public était attendu je pense
que c'est mieux de l'entendre ce qu'ils
disent est peut-être que là le rôle des
politiques changent le fait de
de se retrancher ou en tout cas de
s'effacer derrière la parole de femmes
et d'hommes qui aujourd'hui sont dans
leur combat défendre l'essentiel pour
nous c'est à dire à haut niveau de santé
là en ce moment il ya un clivage qui se
fait entre ceux qui décident dé ceux qui
travaillent et on essaye justement de
rapprocher un peu les choses alors
benoît hamon willfeld et dans les
sphères un peu de ceux qui justement
décide
ces choses là et c'est bien qu'ils
rencontrent les autres qui sont sur le
terrain ceux qui sont écrits passion
l'ancien ministre socialiste est ensuite
allé à aubigny les sombernon une petite
salle attendait loin des meetings de
campagne
mais qu'importe benoît hamon a toujours
les mêmes convictions
j'essaye d'apprendre voilà deux de ces
confrontations de ces moments où on va à
la rencontre des français on se rend
compte que ses idées ne sont pas
forcément phase à ce moment là avec la
population on rencontre aussi qu'il ya
une pression vote utile tout ça c'est
beaucoup appris et je mets ça m'empêche
pas de me continuer à me battre pour ce
que je crois juste benoît hamon
attendait 400 personnes ce soir pour une
dernière conférence donc en côte d'or
son mouvement compte trois comités de
soutien